good afternoon my name is Karen Horner
I'm an instructional coach with the
Varni charter school initiative and I'm
here to talk a little bit about the 72
phonograms that your students have
worked hard to learn for over 3/4 of the
school year the program they have worked
with the curriculum is explicit phonics
and works with specific letter sounds
it's ideal that it's taught in class but
right now obviously that is not the case
so I would like to share with you those
72 phonograms on a sheet that will be
made available to you and to kind of
explain how that works and how it can
help you as the parent so let's take a
look at what you would have access to
this specific sheet has 50 of the 72 you
would receive all 72 and then there are
also an additional four let's focus on
this from right for right now so you'll
have three important columns that you'll
need to understand and know about things
that your student already knows the
first column contains the phonogram the
second column contains the sound of the
phonogram so the slash marks let you
know that it's a sound to be pronounced
those marks are not written by the
teacher they won't be written by you as
a parent and they're not written by the
student they're simply there to let you
know that that is a sound a lowercase
letter indicates that that sound is it's
is that letters first sound or it's
short sound a capital letter indicates
to you that that letter is giving its
second sound or it's long sound or its
name so in the case of oh saying oh its
name and then there are also included
with some of those as students move on
longer definitions that go with that
sound and your students have learned all
of this in the third column there is a
key word or a clue word to help you
understand how this sound is utilized so
students have not
and these words they are simply there as
a reference or a guide for you
so for example the phonogram see says as
its first sound and as its second sound
it's in car and in city so each sound
has a word to help you understand how
that works let's go ahead and go through
the first eight just to understand that
a little bit better
so we looked at see let's look at the
phonogram Oh
so it has three sounds the first one is
ah and not the second is Oh n-no and the
third so if you see this funny double O
and you're wondering oh my goodness I
don't know what sound to tell my student
that is you have a word over here to
help you and you will know from the word
- that this double O signifies that the
sound is boo and for the letter G or the
phonogram G we have good and get and in
giant D did a has app in at a in eighth
and awe and talk so let's see that's one
so s will have as its first sound and
sit and lose enhance F and then I will
have it as in it I as in fine and E as
in machine so you have ass understanding
of each phonogram the sound that it
makes and then a word to help you
understand what that sound is the next
part I would like to share with you is
that your students have also learned how
to mark all of these sums within a word
so if you have a paper to pencil this is
the time where you are going to be
taking some notes so
students learn in addition to the sounds
and some of the definitions that go with
the sound they learn that they underline
phonograms of two or more letters so
they are gonna underline wherever they
find two or more phonograms together
they also learned that a phonograms
first sound is not marked so if it's if
the C is saying if the O is saying ah
if the G is saying it's the aliasing
yeah it's it's not marked in any way
it's just a known that it gets nothing
there so I would not put anything by
this o because it's saying its first
sound and not ah sounds other than first
sounds are numbered so in the example of
scent and great this C is going to get a
number 2 because it's the second sound
that you hear in that phonogram so
students have learned that they put a
little number 2 above that letter in the
example over here ei that phonogram says
e a and in the word great it's saying
it's third sound that long a or saying
its name so you would put a number 3
above that photograph so we've got
underlining phonograms of two or more
letters a phonograms first sound doesn't
get any mark sounds other than the first
sound are numbered students have also
learned that they underline a vowel when
it is saying its own name so examples of
that would be
the a and crazy' is saying its name a so
it gets underlined the I and find is
saying its name so it gets underlined
and the e and B is saying its name so it
gets underlined and then the last
students have learned that they double
underline a silent phonogram example the
B is not pronounced so it gets a double
underline to help you know that it is
silent so as parents you will have
access to all of the sounds the keywords
and the phonograms hopefully you were
taking some notes to know how to mark
those and then also I'd like to share
too two important ways to practice those
photographs with your student the least
effective way is to show them a
photograph and ask them to say it so if
you write on a piece of paper or you
write on a 3x5 card and you show them
that phonogram they should be able to
tell you to to letter used only after a
single vowel that says at at it they
should be able to say that when they see
that phonogram so that's one way you can
practice you can go through and give
them each phonogram and they should be
able to tell you the definition or the
sound that goes with it the other way is
for you to tell them the sound so you
are gonna be telling them and then
you're gonna expect them to write on
their paper the letter C or you might
say or the erv her and they will write
ER on their paper so two different ways
that you can practice the whole way this
is helpful as you go back and you review
and practice phonograms and spelling
words with your student during this time
when you're at home you have phonograms
you have markings and one other I guess
one
thing that I'd like to make you aware of
this kindergarteners have learned and
mastered all the way to number 26 they
should know those phonograms inside out
and backwards they're introduced to the
next 20 so they know those that what as
well and they work with them they're not
way too solid on them and at the very
end of the school year during
kindergarten they are learning those
last 22 those last 26 phonograms
although those aren't expected to be
mastered first graders through sixth
graders should know all of these and be
able to mark them within a word so if
you are at home with a student that is
in one of the upper grades use this
chart provide them with words and give
them the opportunity to practice those
phonograms I hope you find this helpful
as you're spending time at home thank
you